but first disgraced FBI agent Peter
struck is now X FBI agent Peter struck
struck who you'll remember worked on
Robert Muller's team and helped
spearhead the initial investigation into
Russian election meddling was fired in
part over the countless political text
messages he sent to his girlfriend Lisa
Paige after being fired struck responded
by starting a Twitter account following
Rosie O'Donnell and posting a single
tweet which begged for money on go fund
me what destructs fiery mean for the
Muller investigation the search for
Russian collusion should it shake our
faith in its foundations Alan Dershowitz
has been following this from the very
beginning he's retired Harvard Law
Professor of course and author of the
case against impeaching Trump he joins
us tonight professor what's the lesson
of the firing of Peter struck for the
rest of us well personally I'm
sympathetic to struck he was an
excellent FBI agent four years and
counterintelligence he made a very very
serious mistake the mistake was not
opposing Trump he's allowed to do that
under the Hatch Act and other statutes
he's allowed to express any views he
wants his big mistake was not recusing
himself when he was tweeting that he's
going to make sure that Trump doesn't
become president that he has an
insurance policy it was clear at that
point that he could not be perceived as
being fair and just and so by not
recusing himself I think he violated his
position of trust I wouldn't go too far
and blame it on the very top authorities
of the FBI they didn't know and when
they did know they did demote him and
take him out of the investigation so I
think it's a blemish but I don't think
it's a fatal flaw in the investigation I
think there are there are deeper and
more fatal flaws but personal sympathy
for struck but ultimately I think it was
the right decision but don't those texts
suggest why he didn't recuse himself I
mean it's one thing to express a
political opinion I do it for a living I
don't think I agree through it's not
just qualifying but he was doing more
than that he was suggesting that his
opinions would in some way drive the
criminal investigation that he was
conducting and that's a subversion of
justice well that's the issue he of
course
tonight under oath that in any way he
was influenced by his hatred for Trump
in any of his professional decisions but
when he says to his friend we're going
to stop him we need an insurance policy
whether there's the reality of
interference or the perception of a
thumb on the scale that's enough to
recuse yourself
that's why Ruud Rosenstein should recuse
himself he is a witness in this case and
the idea that you can be the chief
prosecutor and the main witness at the
same time is such an obvious conflict of
interest that I don't understand how we
can continue to go forward running this
investigation so we have at least two
major conflicts of interest and I think
it does raise some questions about the
integrity in the investigation but let's
wait and see Muller himself I think is
nonpartisan I don't think he cares
whether he helps Republicans or
Democrats he's a zealot
some say overzealous a prosecutor and
he's using tactics that I have
disapproved of for 50 years going after
man afford in order to squeeze him but I
get him to sing or to compose those are
very questionable tactics but they're
used over and over again against people
sometimes innocent people well they
certainly are you're right and it's a
wake up for a lot of us who have made
excuses for prosecutorial misconduct
over the years I and I and I hope minds
are changed about it going forward but
back up just one second to what you said
about rod Rosen Stein not recusing
himself have you ever seen anything like
this before someone conducting an
investigation overseeing it and being a
witness in it why wouldn't he recuse
himself I don't understand it I just
don't get it I wonder if he's worried
that the person who replaces him as
being in charge of the investigation
remember that his boss can't do what
Jeff Sessions recuse but I'll tell you
if one good thing has come out of this
thing one bad thing is that civil
libertarians and liberals have stopped
being skeptical of prosecutors now every
prosecutor every FBI agent are wonderful
wonderful people we can't criticize them
but if conservatives now become
supportive of at least probing
prosecutors and looking over their
shoulders and
the question who will guard the
Guardians I think it will be a very good
thing for America and a very good thing
for civil liberties which is why
although I voted for Hillary Clinton I
am strongly supportive of keeping the
Civil Liberties argument in the
forefront as we go forward in this
investigation well sure why would you
want unchecked power people with feet
with the power to destroy your life to
shoot you to have no oversight it's it's
terrifying professor thanks for letting
it I think it's a good thing a good
thing that conservatives now appreciate
that thank you